It is going to be a very, very ugly several
years for the Trump family.
Donald Trump's organization is under criminal
investigation now on the eve of Donald Trump
leaving office.
And I expect that January 21st, twenty twenty
one, meaning Thursday is going to be a fascinating
day for Trump News.
Trump is about to get whacked from three hundred
and sixty degrees with all sorts of investigations.
CNN reporting that the Manhattan district
attorney's office is expanding its criminal.
Yeah, this is a criminal investigation into
the Trump organization's finances.
It will include the family compound in Westchester
County.
Prosecutors are interested in this property
called Seven Springs because it is related
to many possible financial crimes, including
understating by dramatic amounts the value
of properties to save on taxes while inflating
the value of those same properties when they're
used as collateral for loans.
We've covered that before this investigation.
Again, it is a criminal investigation.
It also is drawing closer not just to Trump
himself, but to Eric Trump, not exactly known
as the smart one.
Eric Trump is the executive vice president
of the Trump Organization.
He was directly involved in the apparent riff
raff related to this property.
Subpoenas are going out.
There are requests for all sorts of files,
emails, correspondence, and this really is
a threat to Trump.
Now, I want to be clear.
This is not likely to put Trump in prison.
These are criminal investigations into the
organization, which would likely, if taken
to their full conclusion.
And if they find guilt, they would lead to
fines and potentially criminal charges against
lower level people.
Now, Eric Trump could count as a lower level
person here.
I don't expect to see Eric Don Jr. or Ivanka
locked up, much like I don't expect to see
Donald Trump locked up.
We have to have reasonable expectations.
But this is something that is going to grow
and grow and grow.
And remember that within 24 hours, Donald
Trump will no longer have the shield of the
presidency to delay lawsuits and investigations.
One of the arguments that has been used by
Donald Trump's lawyers with some degree of
success for the last four years, even while
Trump was was the nominee, the Republican
nominee back in 2016.
One of the arguments that Trump lawyers have
used is this would encumber Donald Trump's
ability to carry out his duties as president
of the United States.
We have to put this off.
But now, within 24 hours, that's no longer
going to be an argument.
And we have both criminal and civil investigations
happening related to the Seven Springs property
and a whole bunch of other aspects of the
Trump organization.
We also are seeing the resumption of sexual
assault cases against Donald Trump.
And while I maintain I do not believe we will
see a former U.S. president in prison any
time soon, and that means up to and including
Donald Trump, this really could encumber Trump
for a very long time.
I know there are some in my audience who think
Trump could end up in prison there awaiting
for the perp walk.
I don't think we're going to see that.
But the next couple of years are going to
be nuts regardless.
Prepare yourselves to be unable to keep up
with the legal fiasco that is about to hit
Donald Trump's family.
It's I look.
Forward to trying to keep up with it, but
it will be really difficult to keep up with
all that the Trump family is about to get
hit with.
The biggest challenge right now facing prosecutors
is that there is so much possible criminal
behavior to investigate that it will take
years to unravel.
They are going to have to break it up into
pieces and different offices, different squads,
different investigative teams are going to
have to look at different elements of it.
And remember, we still have money laundering
through the campaign.
There are allegations that close to I believe
it was 160 or 170 million dollars was effectively
laundered.
These were donations from Trump supporters
meant to go to the campaign.
Hundreds of millions of dollars were reportedly
laundered through a company controlled by
Trump's former campaign manager, Brad Parr
scale, and used to be funneled back to Trump
family members and to shell corporations with
the doing of Jared Kushner.
That story alone like that has nothing to
do with the Seven Springs property that has
nothing to do with lies told for tax benefits
by the Trump family.
It that's a separate story.
The campaign money laundering story that one
alone could take two years to unravel.
So regardless of what comes of it, this is
going to be hell for the Trump family for
years.
The legal fees are going to explode.
Whether Trump will pay them is a question
that remains open.
We already know that even though Rudy Giuliani
was building 20 grand a day for his work on
Trump's so-called election fraud campaign,
Trump has said don't pay Rudy.
So who knows whether the lawyers will be paid?
But millions of dollars in legal fees will
be billed and it is going to be a wild couple
of years.
So I hope you'll be with us for it as well
as tomorrow.
For Joe Biden's inauguration will be starting
at 11:00 a.m.
Eastern Time, live on YouTube, Twitter and
Facebook.
You can also follow us on Instagram at The
David Pakman Show and follow me on Instagram
at David Pakman